So all of the lies from the administration
about the Russian bounty story have completely
imploded and fallen apart.
And the reason that they've fallen apart is
that even if the lies were true, they would
only expose new problems.
So let me give you an example.
If Trump really hadn't been briefed about
the Russian bounty's situation, that's the
problem.
Why wasn't he briefed?
That would be an absolute and total disaster,
given that we know the topic got to the National
Security Council if the Russian bounty situation
was in his presidential daily briefing months
ago.
Why doesn't he remember?
Is it a memory problem?
That's also a huge problem.
In other words, the explanations we've heard
so far, if true, would all just be indicative
of additional new and even bigger problems.
And to sort of reset the story, the news broke
over the weekend that there were reportedly
Russian bounties.
These are like cash bonuses offered to Taliban
linked fighters if they were able to kill
U.S. or coalition troops in Afghanistan.
They would get a cash bonus, OK.
That's absolutely and utterly insane.
Initially, the White House was silent for
I believe it was 24 hours.
Trump was not briefed about it.
We were told multiple reports came out later
that Trump had been briefed as early as 2019
to as recently as spring.
And eventually we got to the specific claim
that the bounty report was in his presidential
daily briefing in February.
So at a press briefing yesterday, Donald Trump's
press secretary, Kaili McEnany, was asked,
why isn't Trump reading the PDB?
In other words, if it was in there?
And Trump doesn't know about it.
Is he not reading it?
Does he not remember?
And Caylee goes bonkers, saying Trump is the
most informed person on the planet on issues
related to threats against the United States.
Take a listen.
Asking you to defend why the president isn't
necessarily reading his PDB when there are
these sorts of issues that the president does
read.
And he also consumes intelligence virtually.
This president, I'll tell you, is the most
informed person on planet Earth when it comes
to the threats that we face.
You have Ambassador O'Brien, who sees him
in person twice a day, who sometimes takes
the upwards of half a dozen calls with this
president.
He's constantly being informed and briefed
on intelligence matters.
But I'm not going to allow The New York Times
to dictate when we give top secret information
and don't give top secret information, just
absolute minimal proposition there.
The lie falls apart when you go too far.
When Trump once said, I am the least racist
person in the world, it was too hyperbolic,
right?
Just say you're not racist.
It would be not believable if you're Trump,
but it would be more believable than I'm the
least racist person in the world.
Same thing here.
Trump is the most informed person in the world
on threats to America.
He doesn't even read his own presidential
daily briefings.
Just say he's informed, like just be less
hyperbolic.
And it would be less obviously unbelievable.
And I think that the sort of key reminder
here is let's not take our eye off the ball.
The three key points about the Russian bounty
story are, number one, they seem to have lied
again.
Trump was briefed or told about this in some
way, shape or form, multiple sources and allegations
that he was told either in 2019 or February
of this year or the spring of this year or
in all of those instances.
That's number one.
That's really important.
They lied again.
Number two, the lies they told, if true, are
only indicative of other arguably just as
big problems like why wouldn't Trump have
been briefed about it?
Number three, Trump was briefed and he still
wanted Russia back in the G7 to make it the
G8.
He still withheld arms from Ukraine that they
would have used to defend themselves against
Russian aggression.
That's absolutely crazy.
And I guess number four, I said it was three
things, but there's four.
Trump has certainly been briefed by now.
Right.
We know now he's been briefed.
So now the question is, what is he going to
do about it now that he's been briefed and
without a doubt knows about it?
And the answer is nothing.
Trump actually tweeted this morning, I don't
have the tweet handy, but he essentially tweeted,
he doesn't believe the story.
Like he's he's just dismissing the story,
despite the fact that we have officials of
all kinds saying it's a credible story.
It's a real story.
It's a story we should believe.
So that's just as important.
Trump now has been briefed.
Doing something?
No, he's not doing anything.
He's just dismissing the story as completely
fake.
Those are the main four points that we should
be thinking about.
Again, when we recognize the importance of
removing this terror as we get closer and
closer to November,